imagine watching a child that you gave
birth to die a slow painful death and
there is nothing you can do but watch
[Music]
they're torturing him you're torturing
me you're tortured my daughter's
torturing my husband are destroying our
family my son Nico Albanese has been
incarcerated for the past five years and
he's been in solitary confinement for
that entire five years solitary
confinement does not only punish the
person that is locked in a six-by-nine
sell it affects the entire family in a
negative way which eventually will
affect the community it's help it's the
last thing I think of it's what I dream
up as soon as I open my eyes in the
morning it's the first thing I think
Mako had the worst Valley feet I mean to
see but take his shoes off and the whole
room would smell so bad I didn't know
what was going on I would wash his shoes
and spray what lie so I'll make him put
him outside and now I smell his shoes
because I'm so desperate Nico at the age
of 11 was diagnosed with bipolar that's
when we began medication Nico committed
a crime he committed a robbery there was
a gun involved no one was hurt but he
still committed a crime and yes of
course he needs to be punished for it
Nico called from jail and the first
thing I said was did you do it and he
said yes and that was it I mean Nico has
always been that honest he was prepared
to take the consequences at the same
time as the adults or the people that
are putting the laws in place you still
have to be responsible and by taking
someone who is bipolar at the age of 19
and putting them into solitary
confinement it's not being responsible
Anika was sentenced in 2012
and the first time I was allowed to
visit was 2015 and that was because he
was found 40 pounds underweight and near
death and that was the only reason I was
allowed to visit I live in a constant
state of panic my biggest fear with niko
is that he will die in prison my
sister's won't know who he is now lose
my son that's my biggest fear now lose
Niko hell knows myself
[Music]